the first day of Pizza Matson
nerdfighteria is the first day of snow
in Missoula good morning John it's not
morning it is evening I mean it's
officially evening as you can tell here
in Missoula because Suns going down
which means it's 4:30 when we said two
weeks of brotherhood 2.0 style videos I
should have pointed out that that would
mean that I would be late with every
video because doing brother - I know I'm
in the video the day the video got
uploaded which meant that I uploaded it
at night every day I've gotten a bunch
of tumblr asks today from people saying
where's your video you said you were
gonna do a video and I'm like it's still
Monday I'm gonna go to the park and
scream for a while and then you'll get
your video sorry I actually have to make
the video that's part of the process oh
man it is cold out I just got a haircut
I filmed a bunch of stuff earlier at the
warehouse I'm gonna show you that now
previously on Pizza nests we were just
it was just like weird things that we
were selling for example this is a
blanket with just your eye as a few
journals left so these are the leftovers
from last year's pizza that's right here
we order extra always in case people
have returned so we always end up with a
few extra of things and then we tend to
give them away on scishow or subbable
perks for project for awesome things
here before that we just did t-shirts
and now we're doing a mix going new
weird Pizza John Pizza mist designs and
also products that we haven't used
before done before this looks dangerous
so it's exciting when things come up on
trucks we don't know we don't know what
all the time close it at all
riki bad day feel smug first when I took
out of the box I was like no and then
they got them the rest of them I write
to ramble for the million dollars
limited edition you think you a package
peanuts think of how we feel that's the
worst cave John your face is fun a glass
whenever I pack things to the dftba
warehouse i can't help but think of the
Phantom of Heilbronn between 1993 and
2009 a woman's DNA was found at 40
different crime scenes ranging from
simple burglary to grisly
execution-style murders in three
different countries in Europe by 2008
police had stepped up the hunt for the
woman a rare case of a female serial
killer they knew a lot about her the
clothes that she wore the drugs that she
was addicted to they also found her DNA
in the car of a man who was accused of
murdering three people
police were totally freaked out because
this man this murderer denied all
knowledge of this woman as if completely
terrified of informing on her she became
known as the woman without a face a
female Keyser söze in 2009 it was
determined that the owner of the DNA
that they had detected all these crime
scenes was a woman who worked at a
cotton swab Factory her DNA was not at
the crime scenes it was on the q-tips
they were using the q-tips to do the
tests and the DNA was already on there
so that's what I think about when I'm
back in your mugs have in addition to a
mug I'm also sending you some skin cells
it drives home how incredibly tiny these
cells really are and how sophisticated
and amazing our techniques for detecting
them have become so sophisticated that
we end up thinking that a nice woman who
works at the cotton swab Factory is a
freakin crime boss also you probably
noticed that I've been ringing every
Pizza John shirt in every shot since we
came back from the warehouse this one
doesn't look particularly interesting
but wood glue egg pizza John you can see
my face in the light of the beat Sajjad
all right John I gotta actually finish
it up with this video I'm actually
pretty late I'm a little worried that I
might not make it but let's hope that I
do now see you on Tuesday
Oh in scream there's more than just
shirts there's also baby onesies and
iPhone cases only for the iPhone 5
though which I don't have
there's pageants and stickers and
magnets in the pint glass you saw
earlier check it out dad